- Places, everyone.
I'm Cody.
I'm a Helpster.
That means a monster who helps.
Come on in.
- ALL: Hurray!
- I lead a whole team of Helpsters.
- I like how you run this place.
- Well, thank you so much, sir.
And everyday,
we help new friends...
- Helpsters!
- ...solve new problems.
- I have a problem.
- We have a problem.
- How can we help you?
♪ High fives and handshakes ♪
- We have our plan.
Every leader should be... kind.
Well, all right, let's get
started on that paper airplane.
- That's very nice.
- Thank you.
- Sometimes silly.
I love dance parties.
♪ Shake that fuzz,
shake that fuzz ♪
- Creative...
We could use some things
in this room to make a pretend sailboat.
- You're so good.
- And most of all... helpful!
- She's the best at clues.
She helped me find my lunch.
- Where was it?
- In my belly.
- We did it, everybody!
Yeah, we did.
♪ High fives and handshakes ♪